seek and ye shall find
curiosity killed the cat the pen is
mightier than the sword actions speak
louder than words too many cooks spoil
the broth the more the merrier the
clothes make the man don't judge a book
by its cover do as I say not as I do
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery the bigger the better good
things come in small packages what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander one man's meat is another man's
poison
absence makes the heart grow fonder out
of sight out of mind
dueling Proverbs are fun but the real
art is in reconciling them for example
when it comes to that last one I love
what Francois De La Roche Buco said
absence extinguishes minor passions but
increases great ones just as the wind
can blow out a candle but fan of Fire